year is a trip around the sun when you
go January 1st to January 1 each time we
do it Earth is 6 hours behind the
completion of one trip around the Sun oh
crap so we ignore the 6 hours if you
ignore it for four years that's a day
bada bing so you then throw a day back
into the calendar that makes sense every
six hours six hours four years I told
you six hours but it's not six hours
okay of course it's a little less than 6
hours so it turns out over a century
you've accumulated an extra day that
shouldn't be there okay so every century
when it would have been a leap day you
take it out Earth orbit around the sun
doesn't care about how long it takes
Earth to rotate on its axis but we do so
we are shoehorning in our days right
with respect to how long it takes Earth
to go around the Sun